[Musique]
transports en commun activités des zones
commerciales vides quartier l'exposition
flâneuse installé à la commanderie
permet aux saint quentinois de
redécouvrir des lieux qu'ils connaissent
bien
à travers l'objectif de sandra hernandez
pendant un mois cette photographe
mexicaine a parcouru saint quentin en
yvelines avec son appareil photo
ce qu'on lui a proposé c'est de
travailler sur le territoire
la découverte de territoires à travers
la ligne
les lignes de bus elle a eu des cartes
de bus et elle a fait les douze communes
en long en large en travers et a là
aussi fait du vélo beaucoup parce
qu'elle a beaucoup aimé les pistes
cyclables et donc est là elle s'est
promené partout
cette exposition s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un projet d'échangé international
autour de la photographie monté avec
l'alliance française de querétaro au
mexique
une première en février dernier
l'artiste français dan ramène s'était
rendu dans cet état mexicain sur les
trois mille clichés pris par sandra
hernandez 17 sont exposés l'exercice
difficile de l'exposition cette capote à
mettre toutes les photos on a choisi des
photographies qui se répondent de
plastic man c'est à dire que les lignes
et les couleurs se répondent pour que ça
forme un ensemble cohérent et harmonieux
cette expérience de résidences croisées
pourrait être renouvelée en attendant
exposition flâneuse est visible jusqu'au
10 novembre dans la chapelle de la
commanderie à il en faut
[Musique]